the live-action adaptation of The Little
Mermaid has arrived and early reactions
to the film are largely positive so why
should moviegoers want to be a part of
its World those who attended the
premiere cite the captivating
performances and the Infectious musical
numbers led by Halle Bailey as Ariel
several lucky fans took to Twitter to
share their thoughts including an r b
icon who knows a thing or two about
making waves with a powerful musical
number naturally after a series of
divisive live-action Disney remakes
viewers are a bit apprehensive about the
upcoming release particularly about the
two realistic designs of beloved
characters like flounder and Sebastian
but a sample of early reactions should
assure fans that The Little Mermaid
offers a faithful adaptation of the
classic animated film strong
performances in the 2023 version
reportedly Drive the film and make it
more lively than other Disney Live
Action adaptations viewers fortunate
enough to catch the film early single
out Melissa McCarthy's portrayal of the
devious sea witch Ursula and David Diggs
Lively singing as Sebastian in addition
to Bailey's impressive depiction of
Ariel
I've been watching you for a long time
now too
when things go pop writer Brandon Lewis
wrote on Twitter I was blown away by The
Little Mermaid some visual issues aside
it's the most romantic and dare I say
magical Disney has been in years the
best live-action remake by a mile defeat
Diggs is the MVP Hallie Bailey is a
superstar and her part of your world is
a showstopper in addition to the
heartfelt performances many are looking
forward to the show-stopping musical
numbers that made the original film such
a cherished Disney classic so far many
early reactions claim that The Little
Mermaid lives up to expectations and
accurately recreates what made the
original so special meanwhile discussing
film writer a Felicia Wade still loved
the film despite some slight criticisms
posting The Little Mermaid makes it
pretty close to being the best
live-action Disney movie however it
still struggles in the villain
Department Halle Bailey is Ariel and I
had literal chills throughout her
performance this is a Little Mermaid
retelling like you've never seen before
these promising reactions should soothe
worried fans who may be apprehensive
about the new remake music is of course
still a major part of this live-action
The Little Mermaid and it still grounds
Ariel's narrative as she travels on her
journey of self-discovery thankfully the
2023 remake reportedly Nails this part
of the film thanks to The Talented cast
led by Bailey one half of the musical
Duo Chloe and Halle Kelly Rowland of
Destiny's Child Fame posted on Twitter
The Little Mermaid is truly an epic
watch the music in this movie freaking
wow you laugh you cry you'll sing along
I know I'm gonna be singing these songs
for weeks to come given her girl group
bonafides this is Major praise for the
music in Disney's latest live-action
remake several early reactions can't say
enough good things about Bailey's
performance as Ariel but there's also
plenty of love out there already for the
film's villain illuminurity writer
Stephanie Ramirez tweeted The Little
Mermaid was an absolute gem hely Bailey
is Ariel no matter what anyone says she
brings in the charm and personality of
Ariel to life Melissa McCarthy as Ursula
was just Chef kiss this film was such a
joy to experience
this was echoed by Fandango writer Eric
Davis who posted that he also got chills
from Bailey's performance and labeled
McCarthy as a scene stealer it seems
like The Little Mermaid will make a
sizable Splash when it swims into
theaters on May 24th
[Music]